when you're kids I can always be  protective  careful you might change Thanks she  think is too much hanging out with us  makes you a loser too but when you're  alone as a kid the monster she was  weaker  you don't even know they're getting  closer until it's too late  but where's the poison ivy nowhere okay  well I'm starting it cheap I'm pretty  sure this is not efficient bathroom  where's your mother  sometimes yes then you probably have  crabs that's still not funny aren't you  guys coming in ah  greywater what the hell is great one  basically piss and [ __ ] phonies telling  you we had to splash around millions of  gallons of gary pee so wait are you  seriously like a [ __ ] donation you have  your kind of a staff and factoring or  some of that mesh so unsanitary your  rulings is Laura coming inside of a  toilet bowl right now here the reason  why we're in this position my eyes will  snicker is it spread eruption  what if she's still here  [Music]  [Applause]  you  you